[Music]
now we tape an episode every day of a
television show and some days we work
hard on it some days not so much anyway
it's a lot of ways it's a very typical
work environment okay just a very
typical office environment and
occasionally as in any office in
Justices occur among the coworkers
all right and since I'm the boss I feel
that I'm the one who needs to address
these and justices and keep everything
in the workplace nice and fair well
yesterday something came up that I
decided I needed to address we actually
have it on video
take a look there's a lot of free food
that comes into our office gifts
different shows companies they send
great stuff here cakes candies and
people really enjoy eating it the
problem is there's never enough to go
around recently we found out that
there's a secret email list that goes
around
alerting certain special people on staff
that there's food here and they can come
get it before anyone else has a chance
so what we've done is we've set out a
nice big ice cream cake and some cookies
and some fruit a table I've got an email
right here we found the email list the
secret email list and I'm gonna send
this out right now it says our friends
at ease sent over an awesome-looking ice
cream cake and some tasty snacks
we'll go fast looks delicious second
floor conference room now I'm gonna send
this out I'm going to see which rats
come to nibble on this unit actually the
act there's a hidden camera in the
conference room and as you can see the
food is out bombs away
okay the message has been released and
now we wait and see who shows up there
we go
okay okay Sharon Hardy's in first
okay what's going on what's going on
okay you were tell he was told there was
cake you were told in an email that went
out to everybody on staff yes okay so
just a few people were alerted that
there was cake
have you ever had any feelings of guilt
like I'm getting tipped off before
everyone else so I can get that nice
do you ever felt guilt a little bit yeah
you feel you've spoken to me but it
didn't stop me from doing it you do you
feel any guilt
I will there was a time when I was not
on the list
and I'm glad I'm on the list now we're
just glad that you're in a lifeboat you
don't care about the other souls in the
water
yes okay I have a question for you the
cake says congratulations from your
friends at E did you have any questions
about what we might be yes we all said
that said what I wonder what we're being
yeah know that maybe we're moving to eat
I forgot next network doing such a nice
with me pal
okay I think this is a traffic the whole
foodies line up you call yourselves the
nominees well that's what the email list
is called it's called the foodies
here Sharon here in such deep truffle
right now first of all can I say I was
watching
we had a closed-circuit cameras watching
you came in the room and you went right
for the cake other people kind of walked
around shy you went right for the cake
and cut into it and you weren't you
promoted recently yes you were promoted
I showed my trust and love for you by
promoting you and this is how you repay
me how come I wasn't on the list didn't
any of you ever think hey Conan his
name's on the show he's the guy that
makes it happen he wants to put him on
the list be honest I never thought about
it no address I thought you had enough
things so I just wanted something to
come I am I like names who's not here
who's usually here name names if Jordan
comes here a lot yes yeah should we go
get Jordan let's get in let's go Jordan
what tell me a little bit about the
secret food list what are you talking
about there's an anonymous that goes out
to special privileged people so that
they can know about good food that's
come to the show ahead of everybody else
what's wrong with that what why not save
it for those enjoy the most how are you
to determine who enjoys what the most I
never claimed that I'm the one that
makes that determination so did you get
the email today that there was ice cream
cake people love just shoving food in
their mouth and may not appreciate what
they're eating why not save it for those
that appreciate it oh my god
and ran novels so you think that you're
superior people think you're better than
everyone else that you appreciate food
more than other people know so you feel
nothing you feel no shame no I don't
feel any shame why would I feel [ __ ]
have you seen that email which you have
gone in and taken the ice cream cake if
there was an occasion to celebrate I
would have better respect for the other
person I don't particularly want ice
cream cake right now how about some
extra-virgin Napa Valley olive oil why
do you have this on your desk I like to
have things on my desk that I enjoy
really that's funny
I don't see any gay porn so I'm told
that more people are showing up in the
conference room let's go see how long
have you been on this secret email list
since the beginning and you never once
thought hey Conan's not here I don't
think about you what's this is the
foodies list you don't eat huh
what are you talking about like not
really the foodies list it's more the
fatties list he's not I I can't Sharon
Hardy she's skinny as a rail how'd you
get that frosting on you know how I got
this when I caught Darren Hardy she
started trying to explain herself and
she spit frosting
he really did ridiculous
there this is what it's all about isn't
it oh oh this is delicious
well anyway I think that pretty much
wraps up this episode of let's catch
people eating cake what a waste of
everyone's
[Applause]
you